In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading, from the Sinaxadion, for August 1, on which we commemorate, the seven Macabees
brothers, Abimos, Antoninos, Guryas, Eleazar, Eusebunus, Alimus, and Marcellos, their mother
Salomoné, and their teacher, the scribe, Eleazar.
These holy martyrs lived during the reign of the Syrian king Antiochus IV Epiphanes, of
the Celicid dynasty, in the years 175 through 164 BC.
Who having reduced the Jewish nation to slavery, sought to constrain the children of Israel
to renounce the customs and institutions handed down by their fathers and adopt the ways
of the pagans?
To this end he decreed that everyone must eat pork, an unclean animal forbidden by the law.
They tried first to compel the scribe, Eleazar, to eat, opening his mouth by force.
But the holy old man spat out the mouthful with disdain.
Remaining death to those who counseled him to feign submission in order to save his life,
he replied, at our age it is not fitting to feign.
For fear that many young people, seeing that Eleazar, has at the age of 90, adopted foreign
ways, might do the same thing because of me and my dissimulation, and that for a brief
span of life.
I would thus bring my old age defilement and dishonor, and were I to escape the temporal punishment
of men, I would not, living or dead, escape the hands of the Almighty.
Having thus spoken, he went straight to offer himself for torture on the wheel.
Under the torture he showed the valor of a young warrior, and called forth the admiration
of his executioners.
At the point of death, he declared with a smile.
It is manifest to the Lord, who hath the holy knowledge that, whereas I might have been
delivered from death, I now endure sore pains in the body by being beaten, but in soul
am well content to suffer these things because I fear him.
And he gave his soul to God.
Seven brothers, who had been taught by Eleazar in the traditions of their people, were arrested
and appeared before the king, like a harmonious choir in the midst of which as a conductor
stood their mother.
One thing alone was important to them, that the choir, with its sacred number, should not
be torn apart by the defection of one or the other of them.
They encouraged one another in their confession with words such as these.
If we do not perish now, we shall surely die one day.
Let us make of this necessity of nature a chance for honor.
The sovereign had the instruments of torture spread out before them, and tried to persuade
them, but, refuting his arguments with inspired philosophy, they replied to him through the voice
of the first born.
We are ready to die, rather than to transgress the laws of our fathers.
Antiochus, beside himself, ordered that this insolence youth's tongue be cut out, and
then that his skin be torn, and his limbs be cut off.
Put to the torment of the wheel, and then stretched on a gridiron, he declared,
cut off my limbs, and burn my flesh, dislocate my joints.
Through all of these tortures, I will show you that the sons of the Hebrews are invincible
when virtue is concerned.
Transfigured by the fire, he appeared incorruptible, and thus fulfilled his witness without giving
the slightest groan.
While his mother and brothers encouraged by the sight, prayed God that he would grant
them the grace of dying with valor as he had.
The second of them was then put to torture.
They lacerated his flesh with nails, and then stretched him on a catapult.
Ready to give his soul to the Lord, he cried out in the Hebrew tongue.
Now, like a fury, take us out of this present life, but the king of the world shall raise
us up, who have died for his laws unto everlasting life.
The third fearlessly stretched out his hands to the executioner, declaring that he was sure
of finding his limbs in the future life.
He succumbed to the torture of the wheel.
The fourth called on the tyrant to find the direst tortures that he might show Antiochus
that he was ready to rival his brothers in courage, and before his tongue was torn out,
he said,
Even if you deprive me of the organ of speech, God hears the voice of the silent.
How sweet it is to have one's limbs severed for God.
In his haste to carry off the trophies in his turn, the fifth went voluntarily to the
tortures.
The next was made to suffer on the wheel, and when they pierced his sides he cried out, the
knowledge that we have from piety is invincible.
These valiant athletes thus sacrificed their lives, one after the other, showing that reason
illumined by faith can not only master the passions of the soul, but is able also to
triumph over the torments of death, for it gives us the assurance of eternal life and
incorruption.
Their mother, Solomone, was present at the torture of her sons, and far from letting herself
be overcome by grief, it was she who exhorted each of them in the tongue of her fathers to endure
the trial with courage in the name of the Lord and their hope of resurrection.
She said to them,
I cannot tell how you came into my womb, for I neither gave you breath nor life, neither
was it that I formed the members of every one of you, but doubtless the creator of the world
who formed the generation of man and found out the beginnings of all things will also of
his own mercy give you breath and life again as you now regard not your own selves for his
laws sake.
The youngest of the seven brothers still being alive, the tyrant made him promises and
having summoned his mother sought her help in saving her son's life, triumphing over every
carnal attachment, Solomone threw herself on the boy and exhorted him on the contrary
to endure all the torment so that she might join him and his brothers in the kingdom.
Impelled by a new impulse, her son then began to curse the tyrant, predicting to him
that he would soon suffer the just punishment of his pride.
He finished by praying that his sacrifice and that of his brothers would appease the divine
wrath that had been unleashed against their oppressed people.
Diakas, wounded in his self-esteem, raged against this holy martyr even more cruelly than
against the others.
In the end, when the last of them had gloriously given his soul to God, Solomone was in her
turn, offered as a holocaust and departed to join her sons in the choir of the holy martyrs.
In fact, although their witness had been before the coming of Christ, these holy martyrs
are in no way less than those who followed the Lord, imitating his life-giving passion.
For it is faith in Christ who, already living in them through the hope of resurrection,
made them triumph over all that held them to the earth.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.